- I hear that you gave
my producers a request.
- I did want to host your
show for just a minute.
- [Kelly] Oh, well we gotta switch seats.
- All right.
- Okay, you gotta be in the host seat.
You gotta be in the host
seat. (audience cheers)
Okay, here we go.
Oh... your...
Is this one lower?
I feel like its lower, anyway.
- Okay, Kelly, thank you
so much for being here.
- You know, it's a busy
schedule, but I fit it in,
cause I love you.
- No, thank you so much.
Truly
- You're welcome, it's fine
- I'm a huge fan, and it's
an honor that you're here.
- Ditto.
- So I have to ask you,
I am exausted doing one podcast interview,
you know, uh a week.
So you do this show every day.
Well, my show, every day, and The Voice.
What is your secret.
- I was just asked this,
and I feel like it was
around my mom, cause
my mom ended up saying,
"you've always been like this"
like in high school I had like 4 jobs,
and I was always doing stuff.
Like at school, like
student council, or in,
you know, a musical, or something.
And Dante's crazy.
Ummm, definitely, definitely
wants a rambunctious
home that one.
- What was your favorite musical?
- I did many, but I'd say
my favorite was probably
Seven Brides for Seven Brothers.
I loved playing Milly.
You know what it was?
This is actually interesting,
I've never told anybody this.
Good job interviewing.
Um, I-I was doing Seven Brides, um uh,
for Seven Brothers, it was one night,
and um, it was double cast that year,
and that had never happened in our time,
and so the other cast got all the shows.
We got like one
[Hiss]
- I know.
Anyway, but, and we worked so hard,
but we got to that one song, One Man,
and it was actually the first time,
cause I grew up singing opera,
It was the first time I
found like, my chest voice.
My gut voi- like and
really started belting out.
And it was like such a freeing moment.
- Wait wait, what's the difference though?
- Um it was like basi-
Oh you know Sister Act?
You know when she does the
thing with the stomach?
Oh Happy Day?
- So its like the diaphragm difference.
- Yeah, it's just using all, it's, yeah,
and it was just kind of
switching gears for me
From doing opera, and you
have to be so perfect,
and you have to be.
It became less about
perfection, and technique,
and more about passion,
and it was a really really
awesome moment for me.
I felt like I was flying on stage.
I've never told that
story in my whole life.
[Audience Cheers]
Well done!
Are you looking for a co-host position?
- I still want- Yes I am,
and I still want to hear you sing it,
but we can do that later.
- I know, I can't remember it.
I'm 37.
- We'll work on this.
- Yes.
Lets do it.
I just love that I look
like Dr.Evil holding like,
uh, you know, its like.
- But he's on my team I
just want you to know.